o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
e eu compartilho da visão dos povos
originais de que a água é Sagrada de que
mantemos uma interdependência com ela e
que todos os ataques feitos as águas
repercute diretamente em nossa
existência essa é uma fala para todo
mundo que tem acesso a água e usa essa
água como meio de transporte para os
seus dejetos eu vou repetir que a
maioria das pessoas faz parte desse
grupo mas nunca parou para se questionar
sobre isso essa é uma fala para todo
mundo que têm acesso a água potável e
usa essa água como meio de transporte
das suas fezes da sua urina de uma série
de produtos químicos
em outras palavras essa é uma fala para
todo mundo que caga na água limpa e eu
me incluo nesse grupo eu sou carioca e
toda vez que eu dou descarga os das
Riachão para o Rio carioca depois para
Baía de Guanabara transformamos enquanto
puro canalizado em baixo do asfalto o
rio que dá o nome de quem nasce na
cidade e que já foi a nossa principal
fonte de abastecimento uma história de
muitos municípios brasileiros mundo
afora que surgir comprometem suas fontes
de abastecimento de água essa água
absorvida de cada vez mais longe e hoje
eu e 85 porcento da população da região
metropolitana do Rio de Janeiro
dependemos da água que vem da estação de
tratamento de água do Guandu a maior
estação de tratamento de água do mundo
localizada no Rio quando na Baixada
Fluminense a 60 km de distância da minha
casa é um caso Claro do saneamento
convencional Centralizado uma única
estação de tratamento de água para
abastecer 9 milhões de pessoas em oito
municípios
e o rio quando a agitação tá localizada
por sua vez recebe as águas do rio
Paraíba do Sul e de outros Rios menores
todos eles considerados constituídos nas
suas margens usando as suas águas como
meio de transporte de esgoto O resultado
é que o povo do Rio de Janeiro conhece
na prática as consequências do despejo
de esgotos nos nossos Rios pelo segunda
verão consecutivo e durando até agora a
água que tá chegando na minha torneira
possui um forte cheiro gosto de terra
causadas por uma alga e só nasce e se
prolifera devido o despejo inadequado de
esgotos domésticos efluentes industriais
e
e foi uma novidade para as classes altas
novidade nenhuma para as classes mais
baixas saneamento além só uma política
pública atrasada é uma política pública
elitista que atende Primeiro as áreas
ricas das cidades onde as pessoas podem
pagar pelo serviço representando
claramente racismo ambiental em plena
crise sanitária causada pela pandemia de
correr de 19 o acesso água é o que
garante a capacidade de combate a
transmissão do vírus e tem uma classe
social que tá morrendo mais por conta da
falta de acesso à água
é diante desse contexto o reconhecer
meus privilégios entendendo eu deveria
retornar para a sociedade todos os
conhecimentos que adquiri cursando
graduação especialização e mestrado
desde 2013 eu me dedico
profissionalmente a militância por água
e saneamento para todos Começando por
quem mais precisa militância é uma
palavra que está desgastado distorcida
pelas redes sociais mas que significa o
compromisso ético e político com a
transformação social que dá origem a
atitudes proativas buscando os recursos
necessários mobilizando as comunidades
de desenvolvendo tecnologia Eu trabalho
com favelas comunidades tradicionais e
com agricultores sem-terra junto com
essas comunidades junto com as pessoas
dessas comunidade desenvolvemos e
construímos biodigestores banheiro seco
Jardim filtrante e várias outras
tecnologias que integram o guarda-chuva
do saneamento Ecológico uma forma de
pensar O saneamento levando em
consideração além dos aspectos
econômicos e ambientais também os
aspectos
o e buscando utilizar tecnologias que
transformam os resíduos e os efluentes
em algum produto como adubo alimento a
energia que possam ser utilizados por
essas comunidades depois de projetos são
sempre pensados planejados e
implementados sob a perspectiva da
tecnologia social que valoriza e leva em
consideração a cultura os saberes e as
práticas locais para propor tecnologias
que vão se apropriados parece que a
comunidade no longo prazo
Esse é um trabalho que demanda atuação
política articulação e ocupação de
espaços negados na maioria da população
às ações que eu participei fizeram parte
de projeto de pesquisa de universidades
e instituições técnico-científicas de
organizações não-governamentais com
financiamento público verba de editais e
doação de empresas e Fundações
e sempre buscando criar casos de sucesso
que possam subsidiar a elaboração de
políticas públicas voltadas para o
Saneamento de fazendas de comunidades
isolados
a fazer esse trabalho está em constante
contato com a realidade das comunidades
que têm direito à água e ao saneamento
negados e traz um constantemente uma
série de questionamentos que todo mundo
que tem um privilégio do acesso à água
deveria ser fazer sempre além de de onde
vem a água que eu bebo e para onde vai o
esgoto que eu produzo que Eu mencionei o
meu caso o início dessa fala quais são
os impactos na minha saúde na saúde dos
corpos d'água da minha cidade dos
produtos químicos que eu escolhi passar
no meu corpo e na minha casa os
alimentos que o consumo contribuem para
a Regeneração para a degradação do
planeta todas as coisas que o consumo
tudo em que eu existo meu dinheiro
contribui para a degradação para
Regeneração do planeta contribui para o
aumento ou a redução das desigualdades
para onde vão os resíduos da minha
atividade de existir na cidade com a
logística envolvida nesse processo a
forma como descartar os resíduos tem
potencial de prejudicar a saúde de
alguém envolvido nessa cadeia
Ah e por que cargas-d'água o cabo na
água eu sou obcecado com essa pergunta
porque ela representa o gravidez
condição do ser humano com a natureza da
qual ele depende
em várias cidades do Brasil tem um alto
risco de passar por uma crise hídrica
serão os próximos anos a água é um
direito humano fundamental ainda negado
há bilhões de pessoas no mundo e
caminhando a Passos largos para se
tornar uma commodity é necessário se
colecionar e mudar hábitos ao mesmo
tempo em que se ocupa os espaços
políticos para participar interferir na
elaboração de políticas públicas
voltadas para garantir o acesso de todos
a esse que deveria servir como bem comum